hey it's me and
my cat she's back everyone how does it
feel
i don't know it's been a long time it's
been a long time
sashiburi dance i thought why don't we
answer some questions because all the
time people are like oh
what is happening with marxian is she
hiding in your basement is she having a
pug factory what is she doing
how is marzia doing and what is marzia
doing hi
factory well first of all we're in your
uh your
clay studio yeah i was working and then
you were just like
we're filming now yes first question how
often does marcia get recognized
by now we don't really leave the house
we don't leave the house
no when it's really like in busy days or
busy times
but if we do go out when it's like a
weekend for example
i think maybe a few times a day but not
as much as a year
usually when someone recognizes me or us
they'll come to me first and then
they're like
let's see you can too in the bare feet
it happens the opposite to them
at the blue lagoon yeah the person came
to me
yeah she was like oh yeah she did that
they were like oh
feelings they seem to make an effort
even to be like oh marcia
i love marzia so much marcia is the best
youtuber keep doing that i wish favorite
spread to put on brand
new i knew that what is mine nothing
bread is for put
and shut the grenade you put it on the
connector bruh
and that's all you need baby girl kid
[Music]
felix isn't it beautiful wait you should
do your voice
isn't our child beautiful same thing to
the ranch
to the ranks with the child they got
your expression right
that's 99 of the time you looking at me
like that
have you both learned japanese yet
nihongo
no i just been listening to like uh uh
a pod it's like a audio or something
but yeah we'll we'll learn we will get
on it how are our game maya
i miss seeing them in videos oh they're
great they are great maya's sitting
right there i'm not grabbing that girl
though because i don't know where he is
he's behind us he's passed out
oh my god hey guys what's up
it's been a long time no one cared that
i left the channel too
oh here's a good one does marzia have
legs
too two
two as in as well yeah but you don't
have one
moving on hey there's a girl
hey guys what's up after proposing to
martian japan are you guys planning on
getting married there or
in any of the countries you were born we
thought about japan
we thought about everywhere on the
planet basically
i really like the idea of a little thing
and going to japan but the more i looked
into it
it's hard more complicated we didn't
know what we're getting into it's like
oh you can go here and we're like well
what happens over there
but we have decided and it's a secret do
they know no
it's a secret
but everything is set maybe in argentina
japan trip
when when marcia since soon march
very soon are you jealous will you
please use smarty's camera to film these
instead of yours
we are you're welcome internet what's
wrong with my camera that's why i had
set it up
look at this quality terrible clothing
i think it's because you don't care
you're going to be scared
no i'm not going to sit here you need to
produce my video
yeah will you invite any other youtubers
to the wedding up here
but we're keeping the guest list very
very small so if you're a youtuber not
invited that means we hate you
totally this is from swee bliss clearly
a fan of sweden why did you move from
sweden and have you ever thought about
moving back here
why did we move marzia we wanted a place
where we
could both speak and be independent
because in italy you would have domino
means we don't know how to lean on you
yeah so uk seemed like a pretty in
between
kind of a middle ground basically but we
really cherished the time we had in
sweden because that's where we got maya
and
yeah that's it was a humble beginnings
in sweden that's for sure
so i think about going back to sweden
yeah but i think if
that happened it would be in the future
how's doggy
how is that he's great he's doing great
he sleeps during the day doggies live
unlike sleep oh yeah doggy is very cute
scary he just sleeps all the time well
let's play with him
next car maybe you don't like that
design
you don't like this design oh it's cool
maybe not on a car
when will your white hose meme review
well first we have to get married
that is the requirement i have to be
married to everyone that holds me never
know it says
[Music]
you knew about me and shapiro what was
your dream job as a kid
yes for you then no i think it's for bob
i wanted to open a boutique
and it was mostly for passion boutique
still stands
boutique salesman maybe a my shop in the
future
perhaps this video was sponsored by my
shop i wanted to
make video games oh yeah but i had no
idea what that meant i was like yeah
sure and then i realized ah
youtuber camera focus on me because i'm
the more important one
how do you feel that much yeah after
quitting you i feel
good the first two months when i first
quit i
really missed it a lot you missed what
making video editing
but also sharing things i feel like i
still share
them but i miss being able to have a
platform where i could speak about
anything i wanted in the same way
but at the same time it has given me
what i wanted which is
the time to focus on something else so
it feels good to have that
feels good man can you speak italian
felix
can you see italiano
oh yeah that's very good
pizza on pizza yeah
okay this one is for me but you should
read it for me bang mary kill
bread one bread two and martian all
right this is easy
kill marzia bang bread one mary brad two
what are some of your favorite games to
play together
off camera well we don't play any games
all of them we play yoshi together on
camera
oh yeah well but not anymore we play
pokemon card
then some video games we play we usually
play switch games
overcooked is good smash bros smash bros
is good
i don't know the names drum and fun
drum and fun that's really fun like that
and you have the legs that you can kick
oh that game yeah that was fine i don't
remember what it's called it doesn't
matter that one
and of course new taco games my favorite
central
for video games say the coupon code can
you buy
20. that's it for 20. that's the poo
punk
how did you know will you propose marty
the second time in minecraft
and any chance recording it well as you
can see i've set up a computer here
marcia it's time to play
minecraft imagine if a creeper was our
like priest explodes and kills us
do you feel you've made it in life now
you're basically best
paul with evil you need to stop shaking
i can't read oh yeah oh yeah
that is my answer female wall man
hue man person what's
her dishwasher it's very lame next one
the joke here was that i'm the one who
put everything in the dishwasher
they thought it could be an educational
moment here for everyone here
that you can learn that man can use the
dishwasher too
okay i use a dishwasher all the time
for hand washing you're more of a hand
washing girl
and there's nothing wrong with that
thank you nothing wrong with that
maybe before we were married i would
shame
but now i've educated myself this is
from enemy man
joey who is your waifu
you always have girl crushes okay you
don't even any i totally do it will be
fine if you said a name
here you go question for marzia do you
really think he's the one i mean
really you've got better men outside but
have a job and regularize monetize
salary
yeah but there is more than money you
know like charm and good looks
like being funny dude i was rated top
five marxian here's a tough one
if you could marry elon musk would you
choose him over marzia for already
engaged
sorry marcia this is the reason i put it
on camera because i want people to know
thank you it's like the bachelor like
the bachelor yeah when he broke off the
engagement he broke up the engaged man
more questions do you want more because
that was all the questions okay well
then
bye well well well well thank you
margiela
that was really smooth for uh being here
you're welcome but also for being my
future wife
of course everyone is invited to the
wedding
check your name check your inbox
everyone that subscribes
are invited it's gonna be lit we're not
giving out any details right you're just
inviting but you're invited you won't
know when
where or how but make sure you
smash like subscribe and also
yeah the floor is yours millions of
people watching
um what do you want what are you doing
putting you on the spot smash like
subscribe buy all the merch